hey guys elects Roy Korea here with a  gamespot news update tom clancy's the  division will be launching in the last  quarter of Ubisoft's current fiscal year  which means it's not coming out this  year and before you say you saw this  coming everyone saw this coming this  information comes from the most recent  Ubisoft investor report in which the  company detailed its launch plans for  the next year this is the second delay  for the division which has been in  development since 2012 and was announced  at e3 2013 the open-world MMORPG is now  expected to launch for pc sometime  between january and march of 2016 which  marks the end of Ubisoft's fiscal year  Ubisoft CEO Eve Guillermo said it is  never an easy decision to move a launch  date noting that this is a move that has  always benefited the company hopefully  we'll see more of the division at e3  next month next month next month is III  for news updates say tuna gamespot com /  news